And your file system has features that extend the privilege levels provided by
the unique file system symantics. This
includes groups and sub groups and. Accesses
for files with both positive and
negative rights. Negative rights is especially useful
for quick revocation. Further, it also introduces
the notion of audit chain for system
administrators modifying the system. I urge you
to read this paper in its entirety.
To get a feel for the extensions proposed in the Android file system. The
main takeaway, however, in this lesson is
how, as operating system designers, we can
take the best solution that is out
there for information security and implement a
secure and usable distributed system. Further, once designed and implemented,
we should be able to bench mark our solution against the design principles laid
out by Salser on information security, and know the vulnerabilites that exist in
our solution. This last point is particularly important to safeguard our system
against attackers. As we mentioned at the outset of this course
module, the topic of information security is fascinating, and it is of
high relevance in this information age. Hopefully this course module has spurred
your interest. In information security, to seek, more, and future courses.